[Music]
in ursula k le guin's short story the
bones of the earth we learned something
of gauntish
magic the magic that is not taught at
the island of roque in the great school
where they teach the high arts but
rather a magic that is connected more
closely with the earth in particular the
the island of gantt
and the people who learn their craft and
practice it there a magic that may be
more connected with the old powers it's
not quite
clear what the relationship is but
certainly a magic that can go into
the very ground the mountain the faults
that can lead to earthquakes and we
discover that ogian who in the previous
earth-sea novels has been talked of as
the mage who held back the earthquake
did indeed do that but he did it
with a lot of help including that of his
old master and of his master's
master as we're going to find out now
this is prefigured in a way by what
nemerley the patterner
at the time that
dals is there
studying at rock and
somebody who could have become a friend
of dulce
what he has to say
neverlay will of course become the ark
mage later on and nemerle says that um
it's a rare gift to know where you need
to be before you've been to all the
places you don't need to be well send me
a student now and then rogue needs
gauntish wizardry i think we're leaving
things out here
things worth knowing
and indeed the knowledge that isn't
there at roke that can be learned
as uh
dulse has done and he's not going to
pass it down entirely to ogn but at
least some of it
is something from from gantt itself
aard teaches gantis matters to dulse
aard by the way is a woman
wizard who he studies with before going
to rogue against the wishes of his
father who is a sorcerer as well and
we we learn about this teaching that's
taking place
so
here we go is as he walked he thought he
thought hard he recalled he recalled all
he could have matters his teacher had
spoken of only once and long ago strange
matters so strange she had never known
if they were true wizardry or mere
witchery as they said on roke matters he
had certainly never heard about on roke
nor had he ever spoken about them there
maybe fearing the masters would despise
him for taking such things seriously
maybe knowing they would not understand
them because they were gantish matters
truths of god they were not written even
in large lore books that had come down
from the great mage enos
of paragon they were all word of mouth
they were home truths
and what do they have to do his teacher
says if you need to read the mountain go
to the dark pond at the top of cemery's
cow pasture
you can see the waves from there you
need to find the center
see where to go in and he says go in and
she says well how else would you do
anything you can't do it from the
outside you have to go in so she's
teaching him the place to read the great
mountain where uh things can happen
geological phenomena right go to the
dark pond and that he'll do a little bit
later on
she also teaches him
the great spell of transforming
she stretched her arms out and upward in
the invocation of what dulce would later
know
it was a great spell of transforming art
spoke the words of the spell awry as
teachers of wizardry must do lest the
spell operate dulce knew the trick of
hearing them right and remembering them
when aard was done he had repeated the
words in his mind in silence half
sketching the strange awkward gestures
that were part of them all at once his
hand
stopped and then he says to ard but you
can't undo this and she says yes it's
irrevocable
dulse knew no transformation that was
irrevocable no spell that could not be
unsaid
except the word of unbinding which is
spoken only once and then he asks her
but why and she says at need dulce knew
better than to ask for explanation
the need to speak such a spell could not
come often the chance of his ever having
to use it was very slight he let the
terrible spell sink down into his mind
and be hidden and layered over with a
thousand useful or enlightening majories
and charms all the lore and rules of
roke all the wisdom of the books art had
bequeathed him crude
monstrous useless it lay in the dark of
his mind for 60 years like the
cornerstone of an earlier forgotten
house down in the cellar of a mansion
full of lights and treasures and
children but it's still there
when he needs it when he senses
something is going wrong
on rogue and so what does he do he goes
and he does in fact read the mountain he
can tell there's something wrong so he
takes his staff and he goes up to the
dark pond and there
he asks where
the question where
is asking
where is the trouble where is the fault
line where is the source of the
earthquake that is to come and a fish
leaps from the black shaking water a
white gray fish the length of his hand
and his eleptic cried out in a small
clear voice in that same language the
language of the making yaved yaved is
the place where he will have to go so he
calls down to ogian in gantt port ojin
stops and says what what is it master
and then he finds out there's going to
be an earthquake he tells the uh the the
captain of the ship that he's dealing
with tell everybody to get out of the
harbor sail for the open sea because
rogue and they're not rogue gauntport
rather is in a long harbor with
mountains on either side and if the
earthquake comes all of that will tumble
down onto the port and onto the ships
and cause great loss of human life
so he says sail out
and then i'll handle things
here along with my master he goes off
and
sends to his master after that and um
there we go his old master was sitting
in the grass near the pond eating an
apple bits of eggshell flecked the
ground near his legs which were caked
with drying mud when he looked up and
saw ojin sending he smiled a wide sweet
smile but he looked old he'd never
looked so old
ojin had not seen him for over a year
helleth was an old man near 80 now and
he was frightened
he smiled with joy to siojian but he was
frightened and then he says all right
i've got a plan for us
we are going to try to do something
about that he's going to work together
with ogian and here is his plan
i think what we have to do is to try to
hold the fault from slipping much you at
the gates and me at the inner end in the
mountain
working together you know we might be
able to i can feel it building up can
you
and he asks uh oj and says i can't feel
it myself what is it you feel how do you
feel it these were technical questions
mage to mage and here we have a very
important point helleth hesitated before
answering i learned about this from ard
we find out that aard is in fact his old
teacher uh he tells ogn oh by the way
she was a woman
so this is very important lore of
earthsy
and dull says
the magic that i'm going to do i learn
from ard
and it's kind of dirty stuff it's not
sticky stuff
and there's a great explanation here he
says it's not rock magic
nothing against the balance nothing
sticky that had always been his word for
evil doings spells for gain curses black
magic sticky stuff
after searching for words he went on
dirt rocks it's a dirty magic old very
old as old as gaunt island the old
powers ogee and murmured hellish said
i'm not sure
will it control the earth itself
and here's where he provides a really
important explanation
more a matter of getting in with it i
think inside
of course i know the words but i'll have
to learn what to do as i go that's the
trouble with the big spells you learn
what you're doing while you do it no
chance to
practice and he says the earth is
straining quite soon now i think can you
hold the gates open my dear and ogin
says tell me what you'll be doing and
halleth says no no no time not your sort
of thing
and he says very old stuff what i'll be
doing i wish i'd thought about it more
passed it on to you but it seemed a bit
crude heavy-handed she didn't say where
she'd learned it here of course there's
different kinds of knowledge after all
uh she learned it here on gantt this is
gauntish magic
and so dals is going to do things on his
end ogn is going to do things on his and
down in gantt port
and then we have this description about
what happens within the mountain
as dulce says the spell
nothing happened as he said the words
art had told him
his old witch teacher with her bitter
mouth and her long lean arms the words
spoken awry nothing happened and he had
time to regret the sunlight and see wind
and to doubt the spell and doubt himself
before the earth rose about him dry warm
and dark in there he knew he should
hurry that the bones of the earth ached
to move and that he must become them to
guide them but he could not hurry there
was on him the bewilderment of any
transformation he had in his day been
fox
and bull and dragonfly and knew what it
was to change being this is something
that mages do
not very frequently because they can
become the thing that they've changed
into
but this is different
this is becoming the earth itself
he says
this is a slow enlargement i am vastning
he thought
he reached out towards yaved towards the
ache the suffering
and then as he comes closer to it he
felt a great strength flow into him from
the west as if silence had taken him by
the hand after all through that link he
could send his own strength the mountain
strength to help
and they do that
he says to the earth in no tongue of man
be quiet be easy there now hold fast so
there we can be easy and what happens
he was easy he was still he held fast
rock and rock and earth and earth in the
fiery dark of the mountain
all that anybody else sees is ogian in
ganport doing his part and so they think
that he
is the one who holds back the earthquake
but ogian says
my teacher was with me and his teacher
was with him when they praised him i
could hold the gate open because he held
the mountain still
they praised his modesty and did not
listen to him
this is a a situation in which
oge and dulce and aard
were all cooperating together
through
time
in order to hold back the earthquake
that would have caused great loss of
life and devastated gantport and who
knows how many other places around the
mountain so gantische wizardry gantis
spells save the day something that isn't
taught and can't be learned at rogue
showing us that there is indeed a lot in
earthsea
in terms of magic that isn't to be found
only in the place where they teach the
high arts
you